after being suspended just over a year
ago due to allegations of sexual assault
jay sinatra wan said last week that he
is ready to return to competitive
valorent
but since his initial tweets the story's
gotten a lot more complicated than just
one controversial player trying to make
a comeback
let's break this whole story down
[Music]
hey before we get into this video i just
wanted to warn you that we are going to
be talking about sexual assault if that
is too much for you then it's just a
warning you can click off now okay so
this all started back in march 2021 at
the time cleo hernandez sinatra's
ex-girlfriend accused sinatra of sexual
assault and abuse she published
documents and detailed allegations that
sinatra was emotionally abusive towards
her that he pressured her to have sex
without her consent and that at times
where she did consent to sex sinatra at
times engaged in non-consensual acts
that caused her pain she also published
an audio recording allegedly of her and
sinatra having sex on the recording you
can hear cleo saying no several times
while the other voice allegedly
sinatra's can be heard insisting they
continue the next day riot put out a
statement saying that they had launched
an investigation into these allegations
and sinatra's team sentinels tweeted out
a statement saying that he was suspended
while the investigation was ongoing
several months later in may riot
released a competitive ruling in which
he suspended sinatra for six months and
required him to complete professional
conduct training before returning to
play remember that last part because
it's going to be really important going
forward in their ruling riot stated that
they could not come to a definitive
conclusion on the allegations meaning
that they weren't 100 sure of whether or
not sinatra committed the acts that he
was accused of to be clear this doesn't
mean the assault didn't happen riot is
not a court of law they don't have
access to police or government resources
it just means their investigation was
inclusive based on what resources they
had access to they noted that it was a
complicated issue to investigate and
really difficult to judge riot also said
they reserved the right to reopen the
investigation if new information comes
to light from either party or from law
enforcement in the statement riot noted
that sinatra did not cooperate with the
investigation to riot's standards they
stated that sinatra quote misrepresented
certain facts made false statements and
did not cooperate with the investigation
in the way expected of a professional
valor and esports player since then the
story has mostly faded from the public
eye sinatra's suspension was up in
september 2021 but no team signed him he
is still a streamer and content creator
for sentinels and he's active on social
media but he hasn't played a competitive
match in over a year and then on april
12th sinatra tweeted this quote it's
been a year since i was forced to step
back from competitive play in that time
i've learned a lot about myself and
grown as a person i am now ready for a
return to competitive play and will be
starting tryouts this week there's a lot
going on in that tweet and it drew a ton
of attention from all over the esports
world plenty of big names in the scene
tweeted out support for sinatra's return
while others were quick to point out
that sinatra was accused of sexual
assault and it felt odd to give him a
hero's welcome back into pro-valorant
but the controversy didn't stop there
two days after his initial tweet sinatra
released a twitlonger in which he stated
that he was never charged with a crime
and that ryde cleared him to return to
competitive play in january an hour
later he published a screenshot of that
email he received from riot in january
which does show that someone at riot
gave sinatra a statement in writing
saying that he was clear to play in
professional valorant tournaments in
case any teams were unsure of his
eligibility but there was also something
else concerning and damning in that
email see remember back in the may 2021
competitive ruling when riot said that
sinatra had to complete professional
conduct training well in this email the
writer implies that sinatra never did
any training at all the writer states
quote for additional context the
training was supposed to focus on
cooperating with investigation however
we feel like you already know most of
the information covered in the training
as an aside it seems completely absurd
to me that riot determined that sinatra
needed professional conduct training so
that he could better cooperate with
investigations in the future and then
decided that he just
didn't have to do it and then they said
that he didn't need it because he
already knew what they were going to say
which can't be true because they
literally said he needed it in the first
place obviously i am not the only person
who found that contradiction to be
extremely confusing and just two hours
later cleo hernandez the woman who made
the original allegations tweeted out
that she was disgusted by the fact that
sinatra didn't complete the training and
said that she had reached out to riot
she also alleged that riot told her he
lied during the investigation alleging
that the investigation was deemed
inconclusive because they simply could
not trust his side of the story the next
day riot released another statement this
time from their president of esports
john needham in which he stated that
sinatra will in fact have to complete
his training needham writes quote we
have informed mr juan the contrary to
the communication and in accordance with
the competitive ruling he is required to
undergo professional conduct training we
have begun working with mr juan to
complete his training the training will
focus on one conducting oneself as a
professional two complying with the
rules and regulations and three
complying with investigations riot
reiterated that the allegations are
severe and that they take them seriously
they also said that they're looking into
how it happened that sinatra didn't have
to do his training and they're trying to
make sure that that doesn't happen in
the future which all basically means
we're back at square one given riot's
initial ruling it's likely that sinatra
will not be eligible to compete again
until he completes his professional
conduct training just after sinatra's
original tweet dot esports reported that
sentinels were practicing without zombs
and that sinatra was allegedly one of
the potential candidates to replace him
on the starting lineup ahead of valor in
stage 2. it's hard to say whether or not
sinatra will complete his training in
time to be actually eligible for stage 2
challengers which means we're probably
kicking this whole issue down the road
for a few months the valerian community
esports as a whole we are going to
revisit the story because in a few
months or whenever he finishes this
training that riot has set out for him
sinatra is going to want to come back
again and when that happens we are
probably going to relitigate this whole
thing all over again but we already know
what each party has to say about what
happened cleo says she was sexually
assaulted sinatra says that that didn't
happen riot says the sinatra lied to
them and cleo says that those lies were
so bad they couldn't use his testimony
as a credible source sinatra's defense
is that no evidence was found of him
committing a crime and while he was a
shitty boyfriend he says he only hurt
cleo emotionally putting aside all this
[ __ ] about riot being unable to
actually enforce their competitive
rulings all those things that each party
said are still going to be out there the
next time sinatra tries to come back
you